es que el presidente de la república
Guillermo lasso ha dicho que contará
toda la verdad en la asamblea nacional
antes que los Ecuatorianos piensen que
busca evadir el juicio político en su
contra que se inicia formalmente en el
parlamento Guillermo lasso afirmó que no
podía dictar la muerte Cruzada dejando
la duda de qué es lo que verdaderamente
habría ocurrido con el juicio político
si todo textualmente el mandatario en su
más reciente declaración la muerte
Cruzada es la aplicación del artículo
148 de la Constitución ecuatoriana que
implica la disolución de la asamblea
nacional en la convocatoria a elecciones
generales adelantadas para concluir el
actual periodo presidencial sucede
cuando la interpelación en contra del
primer mandatario ecuatoriano ingresa a
su tercera etapa en la comisión de
fiscalización del parlamento Guillermo
lasso insistió en su inocencia y opinó
que los magistrados de la corte
constitucional no leyeron toda la
documentación y aseguró que se le
pretende censurar sin que todos los
hechos hayan pasado por la justicia
ordinaria manifestó durante una
entrevista en el canal local ecuavisa el
presidente Guillermo lasso aseguró que
no existe peculado como se le acusa y
demostrará el crecimiento económico de
la empresa pública flota petrolera
ecuatoriana flopep retiró que el
expresidente Rafael Correa el exalcalde
de Guayaquil Jaime nebot y el dirigente
indígena leónidas Isa Busca destituirle
pero también aseguró que según él
demostrará nombres de las asambleístas
que supuestamente están vinculados con
La Mafia álvareza algo que ya fue tomado
como una amenaza en el parlamento y que
después de decir la verdad evaluará si
aplica la muerte Cruzada